hello everyone
i'm sophia hu a data management
specialist based in tokyo
today i'm going to talk about how cloud
spanner
helps gaming companies more than that
nice their
gaming application and better players
experience
ml can help you predict many things
today
and it's amazing but one thing it cannot
predict
is the success of a game so
what are we trying to solve here with
our database solutions
on predictability compute is very easy
to scale
you need more resource you add more
server when the game
gets a lot of players database is
usually the bottleneck
because legacy db like mysql are not
designed to scale
horizontally how do gaming companies
solve the database scaling problem well
by using a technical called shorting
the first one shirts data by player's
name
the more you was believe the db the more
players
your game will handle second one is
realm sharding
this is typical in mmorpg where
you create new parallel worlds when you
need to
handle more players if a single database
server can handle 10 solvent players
then they have to manage 100 servers for
each mailing players
last one is platform sharing where you
will separate players population
by platform
what if you could simply scale your game
backend
that's where clause banner comes in
clause banner is the first enterprise
grid
globally distributed and strongly
consistent database service
built for the cloud specifically
to combine the benefit of relational
database structure
with non-relational horizontal scale
what are the key benefits
of using class banner for gaming
application
manually sharding makes it difficult to
maintain consistency
and transactions across your shirts
clause banner gives you relational data
and horizontal scaling
it optimizes performance by
automatically shorting the data
based on the load and data sites
customers
who are using rdbms want more power and
are
considering a scalable non-deep database
spanner allows them to keep their
relational data
and can be scaled cloud spanner has no
plan downtime
for maintenance with fully automatic
data replication and server redundancy
and it delivers up to five nights of
availability in multi-region instances
also cloud spanner users can make a
schema change
while serving traffic with zero downtime
with banner in a multi-region
configuration any update
is automatically replicated across
regions
so that you don't have to add extra
logic
for that in your application let's take
a look
at some examples of companies using
spanner niantic learned about how google
cloud can help gaming companies
ensure they have enough scale for a
surprise hit
with pokemon go pokemon go widely
succeeded
the team's capacity estimates and they
use
google cloud datastore to
scale to over 50 times their predicted
worst case
scenario after a few years
niantic migrated from datastore to
spanner
which reduces their operational cost and
improved latency
another example is dragon ball legends
from bandai namco with klaus banner as a
backhand
db bme focused on developing
an amazing game instead of spending time
on database
capacity planning and scaling by using a
fully managed
scalable database they drastically
reduce the risk related to human errors
as well as operational overhead let's
take a quick
deep dive into spanner and some of the
benefits
of cloud native the google network
offers better reliability speed
and security performance as compared
with
non-deterministic performance of the
public
internet or other cloud networks
spanner's capabilities are all augmented
by our
global private fiber optic network
that stitches together all of our
services
and allow us to provide low latency
back-end
spanner has two type of instances
regional or multi-region instance
the diagram represents a two node
regional
instance for each node clause banner
will
create three synchronous replicas
cross zones each long
in the region contains a field replica
of the database with multi-region
configuration
cloud spanner will create up to nine
replicas
for each node these additional replicas
enable you to read data with slow
latency
from multiple locations close to or
within the regions
in the configuration here i'd like to
highlight
the new multi-region instance
configuration in asia called asia one
with tokyo osaka and seoul region
it's also mentioned that true time is
essential to make spanner work
as well as it does so what is it and how
does it help
true time is a way to synchronize cloud
clocks
in all machines across multiple data
centers
the system uses a combination of gps
and automatic clocks to give an accurate
source
of time for all google's application
cloud spanner assign a timestamp
to every read and write transaction
different nodes
can make decisions about the order of
transactional operation
made from other nodes by simply
comparing these
timestamps enables applications to
generate
monotonically increasing timestamps
which allow the system to behave as if
all transactions were executed
sequentially even though cloud spanner
actually runs them across multiple
servers
in multiple data centers for higher
performance and availability
it's a combination of google fast
redundant
global network and true time makes
google cloud banner
external extensive possible so how do we
spread the data to spinar nodes
each table in the database is broken
down into several what we call
splits use range of the primary keys
all of the data in a split is physically
stored together
in a replica and clause manner servers
serves each replicant out of a
independent failure
zone for example this table is separated
into three slits
used wrench of the keys in reality
the number of splits can vary according
to the amount of
data and the splits are rebalanced
dynamically
depending on the amount of data and load
so for the three node instances we saw
previously
it could be managed like this going back
to our original
scenario with each node handling three
of the
splits but remember that the table and
the nodes
are replicated across three zones how
does that work
look across the three zones each split
is replicated in all three zones
use pixels consensus protocols one of
the longs
is determined to be a leader the leader
is responsible for
managing right transactions for that
split
while the other replicas can be used for
reads
every write operation must pass the
modularity quorum
vote for different speed splits
different zones can be become leaders
thus distributing the leadership roles
among all the clause banner compute
nodes
it's using the distributed mechanism of
splits
leaders and replicas that clause spanner
gains
both its high availability and
scalability
let's talk about what scalability looks
like
in practice by increasing the number of
nodes
you add capacity a node can handle
around
2000 writes per second and 10
000 read per second imagine we're
approaching launch day
for our game and based upon the
throughput capability of a spanner
we've determined that we need a three
node cluster
for a total potential threshold of
six solvent writes per second and
thirty something reads per second based
upon
our best estimates we've determined that
three nodes of spanner should be
sufficient
for anticipated launch day load
you can configure class performance
capacity
with the number of nodes shortly after
launch
the game goes viral and
traffic search pushing the spanner
instance
past performance thresholds we can
easily go in
and add an additional node to our
instance once the node has been added to
the
instance the nodes up there
pointers to the splits noted
it's moved now with the additional note
we have a new performance ceiling of 40
000 reads per second and 8
000 write per second and performance
begins to
establish crisis averted
and with a minimum amount of us no
frantic
re-architecting restarting
re-platforming
of the data behind the scene this is
spanner
dynamically restarting the data after
some time
performance returns to research levels
and we find ourselves with significant
additional
capacity to help save cost we decide to
edit
the instance and remove the additional
note
that had been added so far
i have described some key concepts and
advantages
of spanner for gaming customers hope i
could give you a quick overview
regarding how spanner can help gaming
applications
with strong consistency dynamic scale
global data distribution and live
operation clause spanner
has been tremendously adopted in gaming
industry and i'm so excited to have one
of our very cool customers
coropla here today to share their story
with class banner thank you sophia
hi my name is taka and i'm a software
engineer for a japanese game company
called
kodopla i will take over from here and
briefly talk about how we use cloud
spanner in our game
dragon quest 4. before i begin please
allow me to do a brief introduction
about the game
dragon quest walk is part of a
long-running dragon quest series
owned by a company called square enix
and here are some screenshots of what
the game of the actual game looks like
this is a role-playing game where you
walk around and fight virtual monsters
in a real world locations using gps
and ar on your mobile devices here are
some numbers
to give you an insight of how much data
we process every day
so the game was released in september of
2019
in japan and this it has been downloaded
over 5 million times
just in the first week currently we have
millions of monthly active users
which are handled by over 10 000 pods on
gke
and through these pods we process
thousands of queries per second
across hundreds of spanner nodes every
day here's the agenda for what i'm going
to be talking about today
first i will start by talking about why
we
chose spamming then i will talk about
how we integrated spanner into our
development
after that i will provide some tips on
how to use spanner in real life
scenarios
so now i'll talk about why we chose
spanner for this game
there are three reasons scalability cost
and stability starting with the first
one on the list
scalability we used to use mysql to
handle all our user data
and we scaled it by splitting data into
horizontal charts
this worked well for a while but when
the numbers of charts
grew to double digits we started to
notice some problems with this approach
whenever we wanted to scale
scaling in and out took days to prepare
and we scaled every month
so we would scale out whenever we
released a new feature to handle the
high traffic
and then we would scale in to save costs
once the traffic eased
by switching to spanner we were able to
do this with one click
and scaling would complete within a few
minutes
the second reason is cost
i've mentioned in the previous slide we
used to spend days scaling mysql
but switching to spanner enabled us to
reduce the time it takes from days
to minutes and that reduced the cost of
operation quite a bit
another place we saved cost was from
code maintenance
charting made the code complex and
difficult to maintain
because the code had to accommodate for
things like distributed transactions and
replication delays
these things made it costly to add
features and fix plugs
the using spanner allowed us to simplify
the code so adding features
and fixing bugs could be done a lot
cheaper
the third reason we chose spanner was
for stability
as mentioned by sophia spanner has at
least 49 sla
which is phenomenal when we self-managed
my sql servers
which amounted to hundreds a small
number of them used to crash randomly
at a constant rate and having these
crosses used to cause a lot of grief
after switching to spanner we haven't
had any of these types of crashes
we've been running this game for 10
months now and we haven't had any major
downtimes
now i would like to talk about how we
integrated spanner into
the game's development here's the
architecture overview
of how it looked like before we started
using spam
as you can see my sql was used to store
all persistent data we
used in the game and here's the
architectural overview after the
integration
as you can see spanner replaced my sql
for storing persistent data
you might have noticed that my sql is
still used for shared data
i'll be explaining that later in the
presentation so now
i'll explain how we actually did the
integration starting with some
background
when we first decided to integrate
spanner into the game we knew it was
going to be a challenge
since the game was already in
development using my sequel
so we did some preparations to make sure
this transition would be smooth and
painless as possible
so here's the process we took to
integrate spanner into development
first we started with a small dedicated
team that ran some basic benchmarks
to check the performance once that was
good
we created a dedicated driver for a php
framework
we were using called laravel doing so
allowed us to use the frameworks orm
which also made it possible to use
extensions we built in other games
so once the driver was written we tested
the driver by replacing my sql driver
with a spanner driver
on an existing game this method worked
well because
he got to see how it performed on real
life scenarios
after that was done we joined the game
development team to educate them
through learning workshops so by doing
these preparations
the game development team was able to
fully integrate spanner in about two
weeks
now i'd like to give you some tips for
using spanner in real life scenarios
the first timer item on the list is
handling bursts of access to shared data
so our game had some small sets of data
which is shared across
all users these are things like item
properties
and monster map coordinates now if we
access these data in spanner
we would get what's called a hotspot in
the database
which caused latency to shoot up
this happens because all the i o is
happening on one slice of data
that cannot be distributed as you can
see in the slide
this is troubling but there is a way to
work around this the way to handle this
kind of data and spanner
is to add a column with a shard number
and insert copies of the data
with chart numbers assigned to them then
what you can do is have the app select
one of the shards at random
and add that to the query and that will
distribute the load
this implementation works but
unfortunately
we did not use this solution in the game
because we figured it was too difficult
to implement
into the framework at the time so our
actual solution to this problem looks
like this
yes we decided to use a self-managed
mysql instead
since mysql can replicate and scale out
easily if all you have
is a small set of read-only data the
next thing i would like to talk about
is handling launch date traffic so as
described earlier
when there is high load on a split it
adds more boundaries to distribute the
load
this works well in normal scenarios
where there is a gradual growth unload
but this was not what we expected to
happen on launch day
no what we expected to happen on launch
day was thousands of users registering
in a span of a few seconds
so we did a simulation of launch date
traffic by wrapping up game bots
that mimic user behavior and this is how
it turned out
immediately after we started the test
the cpu usage shot up
and latency of the queries increased to
a point where it was unplayable
the reason this happened was because
fanart could not make the splits fast
enough to handle the huge amount
of data that was being inserted so we
concluded that in order to make spanner
handle this massive traffic
we needed to make the splits before the
launch so this is how we resolved the
issue
the feds founded just enough queries to
allow the load based split to trigger
and increase the number of queries
gradually until there was enough splits
to handle the desired tps
this was a tricky process because if we
fed it too many
the cpu would starve which slowed down
the splitting process
but if we gave it too little there
wouldn't be enough load to trigger the
split
so we had to monitor the metrics
constantly to ensure that we fed spanner
the right amount of queries
since this was a tedious task that took
hours to complete
we made a warm-up app that automated the
whole process
and here's an illustration of what the
whole process looks like
so in addition to what i've just
described there are two things you
should
be aware of when doing a warm-up
so number one is do not drop the tables
after the warm-up
in most cases you would want to delete
dummy records that were inserted
during the warm-up but don't do it by
dropping the tables because that will
also clear the splits you should delete
individual records instead
since that will allow the splits to
remain so the second thing you should
know is
to warm up 24 hours before the launch
spanner seems to merge the splits if
they aren't being accessed for over 48
hours
so make sure you warm up your database
48 hours
prior to launch so the last thing i want
to advise
is how to scale in so in this game we
scaled in and out
fairly often based on how much traffic
we're expecting for the day
scaling out is simple since all you have
to do is increase the number of nodes in
the ui
and wait a few minutes for it to be
deployed scaling in however
is a bit more tricky when we scale in by
reducing the number of nodes
too aggressively we notice that the
latency increase for some users
these latencies range from a few
milliseconds up to something like 30
seconds
so we resolve this issue by forcing
spanner to time out in three seconds
and return a retry response which asks
the client to retry after a few seconds
in addition to that we now reduce the
number of nodes in small intervals
since the latency seems to be
proportional to the number of nodes we
reduced
we managed to minimize the delay enough
no retries occurred
on the client by reducing the number to
one node per five minutes
so the takeaway here is don't try to
reduce the number of nodes in one go
but reduce them gradually in small
intervals that's all i have for you
today
thank you for your time handing it back
to you sofia
thank you taka for your great story
for the next steps we have a few more
sessions about spanner so if you have
time
please please watch them as well also
we have demo and quick lab about spanner
as well
please try them out okay that's all for
today from us
thank you for watching